speaking of people running for president
we have some
potential uh presidential nominees
in 2024 and the question is who are they
going to run against
are they going to run against joe biden
are they going to run against kamala
harris well joe biden was recently
giving a press conference and during
that press conference
he forgot the name of the pentagon
his secretary of defense and then had to
be told where to go
after he left the podium i want to thank
you both and i want to thank
the the former general i keep calling
him general
my my uh the guy who runs that outfit
over there
uh i want to make sure we thank the
secretary
for all he's done to try to implement
what we just talked about
and for recommending these two women for
promotion
thank you all may god bless you all and
may god protect our troops
oh all right now in turns basis kamala
faces okay one of the
service women and then huh where do i
turns he's got his back to the reporters
where do i huh wait a minute
where's that guy what's that guy this
the general he's not a general i know is
he's a
is he a lieutenant no he's not he's more
than it was his secretary secretary
that's right secretary of what
anyway thank you
somebody tells me that guy is not going
to be the nominee in 2024
we are like two months
into his first not even not even like a
less than a month and a half into his
first year in office and the guy can't
remember the name of his cabinet
secretaries
so what does this mean for 2024
is it kamala maybe who runs against
kamala lots of
people mike pompeo intimating that he
might be interested
in running ron desantis seems poised to
run
lots uh my colleague here candace owens
has said she might run for president
uh lots of other lots of other uh
candidates about to throw their hats in
the ring we might be
not not at the beginning of the new
biden arrow we might we might be at the
end of something here and what what
comes next
i suppose it's up to us if you enjoyed
that break from disinformation
historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video